puisque vous les doutes et ses produits
il y aura un grand mystère
les prêtres mariés
[Musique]
une boulangerie peut gaspiller jusqu'à
30 kg de pain par exemple chaque soir ce
qui fait plusieurs tonnes on est entre
deux et trois tonnes par an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya toujours des invendus dans
les boulangeries pourquoi parce qu'il
est très difficile de prévoir combien on
va avoir de clients en fin de journée de
même il ya beaucoup de boulangerie qui
veulent avoir encore du choix jusqu'au
dernier client pour tout simplement et
c'est leur métier c'est normal de ne pas
tarder de clients et a toujours que ce
soit un peu ou beaucoup mais il ya
toujours des pertes
[Musique]
moi le premier j'ai été
admiratif de ce projet je me suis
impliqué à 100% et je trouve que pouvoir
revaloriser ce pain pour jeter
malheureusement et qu'on a la
possibilité de repasser dans certains
produits mais je trouvais ça super mais
vraiment un projet phénoménal le procédé
maintenant comment ça fonctionne on a
mis en place avec les boulangers il le
met dans le fond boulanger à une
température basse pour pouvoir le sécher
donc maintenant on va le moudre pour le
transformer leur cas
[Musique]
oui
au revoir
voyez c'est une opération quand même qui
est extrêmement simple
c'était vraiment une découverte que
c'était nouveau c'était comme de l'or on
découvre et aux leurs et puis mais il
fallait en faire quelque chose voilà le
transformer
[Musique]
je vous ai préparé on l'a des muffins
sucre est plutôt que de la farine de riz
y est on a mis justement notre poudre
donc qu'on incorpore à l'intérieur
j'incorpore mon liquide donc c'est du
lait et des oeufs à la suite d'un corps
pendant mon sucre et pour finir mon
beurre fondu et donc ensuite c'est poché
dans des petits un cirque on a des
petits moules
donc on va les mettre au fond ces prêts
franchement mais c'est très bon s'est
plutôt élevé pense pas que c'est fait
deux
avec cette farine d'un tonneau les deux
coups puisque on récupère ce cap a été
utilisée quoi donc
non seulement
[Musique]
le gaspillage alimentaire c'est une
question qui concerne chacun d'entre
nous que ce soit autant les
professionnels ici dans les boulangeries
pour lesquels on essaye de trouver des
solutions que les particuliers et ça
tient à plein de choses que chacun peu
derrière déployés à titre personnel pour
arriver à ce qu'on semble on ait un
impact on puisse avoir un impact global
pour réduire ce gaspillage alimentaire
[Musique]